we could have  the incumbent president joe biden  not run for re-election  the sitting vice president kamala harris  trying for the nomination and losing it  potentially she's very unpopular right  now that's just a fact it's not my  opinion i mean kamala harris is  perfectly fine person she's just not  very popular right now so you could have  biden say i'm not running for reelection  harris saying i am running and  democratic voters might choose someone  else so the sitting vp might lose the  democratic nomination on the republican  side you could have a former president  one-term president donald trump who lost  was removed from office  trying to become the nominee  that alone would be unique and he may  also lose it's not obvious that donald  trump would win he probably would win  based on current polling but ron  desantis is surging every two weeks  every week or two ron desantis is doing  better and better in 2024 betting  markets